could this drive a stake through cancer
culture teachers union boss Randy
Weingarten is pushing a social media
scrub tool think quote our Union is here
for you to help you future proof your
social media this powerful tool scans
your social media to catch forgotten
posts that may not reflect who you are
today
and I do say oh my God honestly well
first of all the best scrub tool is you
don't have to tweet ridiculous things
that's a number one and also the left
invented cancel culture and now they
need a tool because they can't get
confirmed by the United States Senate
because they say ridiculous things that
this is absurd
I kind of think it's helpful
no yeah you gotta first observe the
timing just last week or she brazenly
proclaimed she wasn't pro-lockdown and
then TWiT on Twitter she was humiliated
by her previous tweets including the
community notes that just exposed her
for her hypocrisy her double dealing
lies she was Pro lockdown they're this
this is a very selfish sad
pathetic person this should be about
students I know it's a teacher's Union
but it's the students who really deserve
Second Chances on social media they're
the ones that have lives ahead of them
that they need to deal with that get
canceled she she sees an old left Winger
man just go go away nobody cares about
what you have to say worry about the
kids that you abandon that you screwed
over for the past three years
judge what do you think
I absolutely agree with Greg I think
that she not only is selfish and sad but
I think she's sadistic I think that what
she did to kids in this country uh was
very sadistic and that she has the hot
spot to come out in May and say we tried
really hard to get the kids back in
school to learn in person that's another
lie because she never cared about what
metric would be used to open up the
schools she denounced Plans by Trump and
DeVos to open the schools she's a liar
and a sadist who has consequences the
kids will suffer for the Next Generation
because of what this one woman did
because of her political aspirations and
her supporting uh uh her desperate
attempt to support politics
okay Jesse take us home politely
I got nothing palette do you know where
she is right now
Ukraine yeah okay why is Randy Gardner
wine Gardner in Ukraine for the third
time yep it's beautiful this time of
year that's what you got
I'm leading the block I don't have to
defend it oh you should
I just think lives of tick tock is going
to be very upset by this because they're
going to be out of material quick if
this goes into place but I just don't
like and I'm with the judge and you the
secrecy
if we've shown these Undercover videos
where they go inside these classrooms
and you have administrators admitting
that they hide CRT they deceive the
parents they change the words around and
now this is another way to make the
truth secret and I don't like that it
looks like they're hiding something and
we know exactly what it is they're all
freaks
you've seen Libs of tick tock they're
all freaks I actually am there's not a
lips of tick tock Aficionado all right
you should check it out
I'm gonna run right home after the show
and do that hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else